heute um 22 15 mit diesem thema
[Musik]
und jederzeit auf phoenix de per red
button und in den mediatheken
[Musik]
phoenix vor ort
ja liebe zuschauer großer zapfenstreich
für angela merkel die nur noch wenige
tage geschäftsführend im amt ist 16
jahre war die aus deutsche
bundeskanzlerin und eines der von ihr
ausgewählten lieder heute abend stammt
von nina hagen du hast den farbfilm
vergessen ein highlight ihrer jugend sei
der song gewesen sagt merkel die insel
hiddensee übrigens die da besungen wird
zählte zu ihrem wahlkreis wir geben
direkt live ab sehr geehrte frau
bundestagspräsidentin
exzellenzen sehr geehrte damen und
herren liebe mitbürgerinnen liebe
mitbürger
wenn ich heute hier vor ihnen stehe dann
empfinde ich vor allem dieses
dankbarkeit und demut
demut vor dem amt das ich so lange
ausüben durfte
dankbarkeit für das vertrauen das ich
erfahren durfte
vertrauen dessen wollt mir immer bewusst
ist das wichtigste kapital in der
politik
es ist alles andere als
selbstverständlich und dafür danke ich
von ganzem herzen
mein dank gilt auch ihnen frau
bundesministerin lieber annegret und der
bundeswehr für die ausrichtung des
großen zapfenstreichs noch dazu an
diesem in unserer geschichte so
bedeutsamen ort des bendlerblocks
mein dank gilt auch dem stabsmusikkorps
der bundeswehr
für die musikalische begleitung
alles unter den so erschwerten
bedingungen der pandemie
besonders möchte ich deshalb zu beginn
auch an die denken die sich zeitgleich
mit all ihrer kraft der vierten welle
der pandemie entgegenstemmen die alles
geben um leben zu retten und zu schützen
die ärztinnen und ärzte die pflegerinnen
und pfleger in den krankenhäusern die
impf teams die helfenden hände in der
bundeswehr und in den
hilfsorganisationen
ihnen allen gebühren mein und unser
aller besonderer dank und höchste
anerkennung
heute am tage habe ich mit dem
regierungschefin und regierungschefs der
länder
noch in einer weiteren pandemie beratung
zusammen gesessen jetzt wenige stunden
später darf ich mich in diesem
feierlichen rahmen nach 16 jahren von
ihnen als bundeskanzlerin verabschieden
wenig zeigt so sehr wie diese abfolge in
welch unglaublicher zeit wird derzeit
liegen die 16 jahre als bundeskanzlerin
waren ereignisreiche und oft sehr
herausfordernde jahre sie haben mich
politisch und menschlich gefordert und
zugleich haben sie mich immer auch
erfüllt ganz besonders die vergangenen
zwei jahre der pandemie haben wir in
einem brennglas gezeigt von welch großer
bedeutung das vertrauen in politik
wissenschaft und den gesellschaftlichen
diskurs ist aber auch wie fragil das
sein kann
unsere demokratie lebt von der fähigkeit
zur kritischen auseinandersetzung
und zur selbstkorrektur
sie lebt vom späten ausgleich der
interessen
und von ihm respekt voreinander
sie lebt von solidarität und vertrauen
im übrigen auch von dem vertrauen in
fakten und davon dass überall da wo
wissenschaftliche erkenntnis geleugnet
verschwörungstheorien und hetze
verbreitet werden
widerspruch laut werden muss
unsere demokratie lebt auch davon dass
überall da wo hass und gewalt als
legitimes mittel zur durchsetzung
eigener interessen erachtet werden
unsere toleranz als demokratinnen und
demokraten ihre grenze finden muss
die vielfältigen herausforderungen im
innern spiegelt sich auch im
außenpolitischen handeln wieder und zwar
nicht erst seit der pandemie
denn schon die finanz und
wirtschaftskrise 2008 und die vielen
zuflucht suchenden menschen 2015 haben
deutlich gemacht wie sehr wir auf die
zusammenarbeit über nationale grenzen
hinweg angewiesen sind wie unverzichtbar
internet neue institutionen und
multilaterale instrumente sind um die
großen herausforderungen unserer zeit
bewältigen zu können den klimawandel
die digitalisierung flucht und migration
ich möchte dazu ermutigen auch zukünftig
die welt immer auch mit den augen des
anderen zu sehen also auch die manchmal
unbequemen und gegensätzlichen
perspektiven des gegenübers wahrzunehmen
sich für den ausgleich der interessen
einzusetzen
meine damen und herren meine politische
arbeit wäre ohne die vielfältige
unterstützung politischer weggefährten
national wie international nicht möglich
gewesen
ihnen allen gilt mein großer dank
ich danke den kolleginnen und kollegen
in der bundesregierung im deutschen
bundestag und im deutschen bundesrat für
unsere zusammenarbeit
ich danke auch für eine politische
streitkultur um die uns viele andere
nationen beneiden
einen ganz besonderen
herausgehobenen dank schulde ich meinen
engsten mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern danke für alle hilfe und
alle unterstützung und das gilt auch für
meine familie
nun wird es an der nachfolgenden
regierung liegen antworten auf die vor
uns liegenden herausforderungen zu
finden und unsere zukunft zu gestalten
hierfür will sich ihnen lieber olaf
scholz und der von ihnen geführten
bundesregierung alles alles gute und
eine glückliche hand und viel erfolg
ich bin überzeugt dass wir die zukunft
auch weiterhin dann gut gestalten können
wenn wir uns nicht mit missmut mit
missgunst mit pessimismus
sondern wie ich vor drei jahren in einem
anderen rahmen gesagt habe mit
fröhlichkeit im herzen an die arbeit
machen so jedenfalls habe ich hier ist
immer für mich gehalten in meinem leben
in der ddr und erst recht und umso mehr
unter den bedingungen der freiheit es
ist diese fröhlichkeit im herzen
die ich uns allen und im übertragenen
sinne unserem land auch für die zukunft
wünsche ich danke ihnen von herzen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
hamamatsu
[Musik]
fackelträger rechts und links
fackelträger war
[Musik]
rechts und links
großer zapfenstreich
richtig
gerade
fackelträger
das gewehr
achten rettete das
gemälde augen
frau bundeskanzlerin ich melde großer
zapfenstreich zu ihren ehren angetreten
frau bundeskanzlerin anlässlich des
großen zapfenstreichs zu ihren ehren
überreiche ich ihnen die urkunde des
wachbataillons beim bundesministerium
der verteidigung
so nannte man das war der erste teil der
einleitende teil die aufstellung des
großen zapfenstreiches die meldung und
auch die übergabe der
urkunde und jetzt kommen wir schon zum
zweiten teil richtig so sehen na ja das
ist richtig nämlich zu den musikstücken
die sich die kanzlerin gewählt bild hat
wird losgehen mit dem ersten lied
nämlich nina hagen du hast den farbfilm
vergessen
von
1974 und wir uns der leiter des
stabsmusikkorps verraten hat 300 yorker
war das eine ziemliche überraschung eine
woche der für zur einstudierung mussten
erst mal engagiert das arrangement
hergestellt werden und dann musste hier
kräftig geprobt werden das gilt ja so
ein bisschen als so eine etwas
subversive jugendfilme geradezu
anarchisch demnach nur in
studentenzeiten sondern auch an ein
system was sie mit denen sie leben
wusste aber sich jetzt in die jugend der
jungen angela merkel zurück nina hagen
war 19 720
stark gefahren
nochmal zu
[Musik]
als den farbfilm vergessen mein michael
ich empfehle ihnen übrigens die die
texte und nachzulesen zdf heute bietet
das natürlich an und jetzt kommt das
zweite gewünschte lied hildegard knefs
hymne für mich soll's rote rosen regnen
wir sollten sämtliche wunder begegnen
das glück sollte sich sanft verhalten es
soll mein schicksal mit liebe verwalten
also zum mitsingen hätte er heute
[Musik]
solche klänge gab es hier glaube ich vor
dem bendlerblock noch nicht sie hat sich
jedenfalls im griff hampel gesehen und
in erinnerung an hildegard knef da
vielleicht heute abend auch ein bisschen
mal lieber sein jetzt das kirchenlied
das dritte der choral großer gott wir
loben dich
[Musik]
so dass die drei wunsch lieder von
angela merkel eine ddr jugend immer eine
große ballade und ein kirchenlied damit
lässt sich schon ein bisschen in ihr
herz schauen sehr aussagekräftig siehst
du unkonventionelle frau und
konventionelle politikerin so hat sie
das auch ausgewählt es ist ihre ddr was
seite die sich in den letzten jahren
stärker gemacht hat auch in
verschiedenen regen dokumentiert er
zuletzt am dritten oktober die sie in
den jahren zuvor nicht so präsentiert
hat es ist natürlich die pfarrerstochter
die hier mit dem religions- lied noch
mal dass auch unterstreicht das ist das
dienende das ist das kultur
protestantische was sie mit eingebracht
hat in die gefahren der macht auch immer
zu verzichten
[Musik]
so jetzt beginnt das eigentliche
kernstück herum man kann man glaube ich
sagen der große zapfenstreich mit seinen
vier teilen einmal das locken als
dargestellt mit den trommlern soll das
schlagen auf dem zapfenstreich
darstellen dann der mass für die
fußtruppen dann direkt für die
kavallerie und am ende der ruf zum gebet
und
dann hören wir jetzt mal dieses locken
das sind ja flötentöne flöten signale
und trommel
das wird jetzt losgehen ja
[Musik]
so das war jetzt so etwas wie das
herzstück des großen zapfenstreiches
oder sondern human also haben wir das
gehört zuletzt die rücktritt also der
ruf für die kavallerie sozusagen dann
wieder das locken das ist eine
festgefügte abfolge genau diese
festgelegte abfolge des großen
zapfenstreiches ist seit 1873 fester
bestandteil und schließt jetzt am ende
mit dem gebet später an die macht der
liebe und am ende seit 1922 mit der
deutschen nationalhymne also das sind
jetzt quasi die nächsten punkte die
folgen
[Musik]
zum gebet
der kann man schon sagen modernen
auslegungen durchaus nicht nur
christliches gebet sondern eine
einladung er zum innehalten zur andacht
egal welcher religion der oder die
einzelne angehört
[Musik]
was her
red
pilz wandert
bis 21
[Musik]
augen
august ich melde ende des großen
zapfenstreich
gerade
das gewehr
wer
[ __ ]
[ __ ] it recht und legt
harket
[Musik]
so jetzt hat der kommandeur
oberstleutnant kai ranke der kommandeur
des wachbataillons des
verteidigungsministeriums den großen
zapfenstreich wieder abgemeldet jetzt
erfolgt der ausmarsch es werde noch ein
paar minuten dauern wir wollten einmal
alles gut gegangen oder
selbstverständnis
das vielleicht einmal noch sagen dass
für sie persönlich durchaus da auch ein
kreis schließt heute abend sind die
gesamte kanzlerschaft von angela merkel
als
teil des wachbataillons dabei gewesen am
ersten dezember 2005 bei ihrem
allerersten einsatz weichen das machen
zum schüler eingeteilt beim
ministerpräsidenten singapurs er damals
an der fahne vorbei gelaufen ist und
dann den zweiten einsatz
ministerpräsidenten indien in hannover
durfte ich selbst kommandieren und heute
bei ihrem abschluss aber das ist
wirklich eine klammer die sie schließt
großer zapfenstreich
[Applaus]
wow
[Musik]
so lernen wir jetzt wieder den job zwar
schon gemein zu kennen
[Musik]
so
viel auszug wenn ich mir hier angela
merkel auch immer wieder sehen um uns
sehr zu bedanken wir uns doch mal ein
dankeschön für die erläuterung für das
haus während dieses abends
und bündeln vielleicht noch mal ein
bisschen
mit professor karl rudolf korte bisschen
lohnt sicher bilanz zu ziehen wie viele
andere auch an diesem abend
beginnt vielleicht nochmal einmal damit
wie angela merkel ihn musikalisch
gestaltet hat das war eine überraschung
hat ja jetzt im vorfeld schon dafür
gesorgt dass große auslegungen
veröffentlicht wurden vielleicht darf
man es aber auch gar nicht so
überbewerten nein weil sie ja so
selbstironie immer wohnt kommt man zu
der dinge die und auch uns immer wieder
überrascht trotz ihrer uniformiert hat
auch so wie sie gekleidet ist wie sie in
ihrer bis zur schmerzgrenze nüchternheit
uns immer wieder konfrontiert mit diesen
dienen momentum gibt es eben auch in
diesem tag anders zur fröhlichkeit hat
sie ja selbst auch gesagt und so ist
auch die auswahl über das man vielleicht
nicht über argumentieren sollte und was
hier alles hinein zu interpretieren wäre
weil die fröhlichkeit des herzens glaube
ich das wird dann auch noch in
erinnerung bleiben als der ausspruch
jetzt beginnt ihre arbeit als
politikwissenschaftler die arbeit der
historiker um bilanz zu ziehen und die
frage geben wird sein was bleibt wir
sehen jetzt dass angela merkel zusammen
mit annegret kramp karrenbauer hier noch
den ausmarsch des großen zapfenstreiches
abwartet sie wird dann abgeholt werden
mit einem mit einer wagenkolonne und
zurück ins kanzleramt gefahren werden
das ist
dann einer ihrer letzten öffentlichen
auftritte sie wird noch in der
unionsfraktion am dienstag
erwartet
keine auslandsreisen mehr
voraussichtlich und dann wird ja mitte
nächster woche so ist es geplant die
amtsübergabe stattfinden also was bleibt
von dieser kanzlerschaft 60 jahre schon
eine muss man ja fast sagen
außergewöhnliche spektakuläre naja jetzt
wird ja auch geklatscht er zu recht
viermal ist gewählt worden die
sicherheits deutschen fühlt sich gut
aufgehoben von ihr konzerten sie nicht
immer wieder gewählt ein
stabilitätsanker ein vertrauens
versprechen für viele menschen da werden
auch verlustängste sich ausbreiten trotz
des normalen wechsels der zu demokratie
dazugehört aber das besondere dieses
tages ist natürlich auch dass sie die
erste kanzlerin ist die darauf
verzichtet hat nochmal anzutreten es ist
nicht abgewählt worden sie hat also
jetzt die einmalige chance das schwerste
für ein politiker würde voll
bedeutungslos zu werden das wird sie
angehen wir sanieren ihr mann an ihrer
seite
joachim sauer tja was werden die beiden
jetzt machen das ist ja die große frage
sie hat immer gesagt ich schlafe erst
mal aus und denke danach was erwarten
sie beim bc als vortragsreisender wieder
erleben ich glaube auch er nicht als
normale bürgerin an der kasse beim
einkaufen wenn wir sie erleben so
unprätentiös so öffentlich und war sie
immer und diese rolle wird sie auch
übernehmen das hat sie ja in den
vorgängern auch immer kritisiert und in
diesem falle wird sie nicht gehen da bin
ich ziemlich sicher die beiden müssen
erstmal wieder lernen zweisamkeit
zusammen zu sein neue wirklichkeit zu
zweit
rote rosen für mich soll's rote rosen
regnen war einer der gewünschten titel
heute
die waren für sie bestimmt eine nimmt
sie mit einem verschenkt sie ja
vielleicht war es auch ein liebesliedern
irgendwann
[Applaus]
das ist ja möglich
so ich glaube man sieht was sieht man
zufriedenheit schon zwischendurch sah
man durchaus auch mal rührung muss man
sagen ja sie war ergriffen bei dem helm
ab lied das hat man eindeutig gesehen
und das ist sehr selten bei ihr
emotionaler aktuell dass sie sieht sich
selbst als oberste sachbearbeiterin
dieses landes und da gestattet sie sich
auch keine leidenschaft
sie haben es gesagt professor karte die
erste frau in diesem amt
auch die ärzte die geschafft hat
selbstbestimmt sozusagen aus dem amt zu
gehen also nicht abgewählt zu werden und
das ist schon das besondere wird es eine
ära merkel dann am ende sein auch in den
geschichtsbüchern auf jeden fall so eine
kulturelle zäsur der merkel ismus hatte
einen bestimmten politik begriff geprägt
situativ zu agieren
reaktiv zu agieren nicht das große
gestalten sondern eher die wirklichkeit
verliebtheit auch nicht die großen
diskussion öffentlich deswegen war das
heute interessant zu hören dass sie
diese große streitkultur sich wünscht in
ihrer zeit vor allem mit den großen
koalition gab es sie eher eine diskurs
allergie die zeit geprägt dass wir
müssen ja erst wieder lernen auch zu
streiten über unterschiedliche ziel also
empörung resistent wie sie vorging
nüchtern bis an die schmerzgrenze ein
begriff von politik der auch mit ihrer
person zusammenhängt sie ist ja als
person nie fähig zu polarisieren und
daran sind auch manche andere
wahlkämpfer verzweifelt
wir sagen hier gerade noch mal einige
der gäste wir sagen den
bundespräsidenten mit seiner
ehefrau
auch ein ehemaliger vizekanzler ist hier
zu sehen rösler das war der frühere
fdp-chef
und ohnehin sind die ministerinnen und
minister aus vier kabinetten angela
merkel hier heute eingeladen gewesen das
sind allein dann auch schon über 50
personen
whistler in der
im schwarz gelben kabinett
ja das ungewöhnlich ist ja dass sie
diese drei großen koalition geführt hat
in dem für die geschichte der republik
ungewöhnlich aber mit ihrer art zu
führen als kanzler präsidentin geradezu
idealtypisch die kraft der macht durch
moderation das hatte sie kohl abgeguckt
und das hat sie auch gezielt eingesetzt
und so hat sie auch mit ganz
unterschiedlichen akteuren
zusammengearbeitet sehr intensiv mit
unterschiedlichen koalitionen und mit
einem vermutlich ja weiblichen
kommunikations und führungsstil auch
alles zusammen galt
ja und sie hat das hat war auch
außergewöhnlich beim g20-gipfel in
rohren quasi eine amtsübergabe
international auf internationaler bühne
organisiert für ihren nachfolger olaf
scholz
hatte man vorher auch noch nie so
gesehen nein vizekanzler wird ja auch
nicht danach automatisch kanzler halt
eine demokratie ist es ja eher
ungewöhnlich bis zum zweiten mal nach
willy brandt das überhaupt ein
vizekanzler dann die chance erhält
gewählt zu werden als kanzlerkandidat
angetreten aber das war mehr als nur
eine geste es war ein zeichen der
qualität unserer demokratie die uns auch
international immer wieder große
beachtung
david wir international auch verbunden
weil wir doch hier eine art von sozialen
gesellschaftlichen frieden auf hohem
niveau organisiert haben und eine sehr
breite in der mitte ausformuliert aus
formierte gesellschaft und das ist oft
beneidenswert aus dem ausland das viel
polarisierte agiert ist also eine
umarmung und konsensdemokratie hier viel
stärker als in anderen ländern das ist
richtig hat nicht zu extrem
wahlergebnissen geführt und es gibt
jetzt vor weihnachten wie versprochen
eine regierung der künftige kanzler hat
jedenfalls in den letzten tagen auch
deutlich gemacht ich übernehme und will
aktiv für eine pressekarte ganz vielen
dank für begleitung dieses abends eine
16-jährige kanzlerschaft das können wir
ja noch bemerken geht zu ende den rekord
von helmut kohl hat sie nicht
eingestellten tage natürlich historische
politische aufarbeitung beginnt jetzt
und sie wird stärken und schwächen
zeigen die letzte krise corona spielt
die heute auch eine rolle hat angela
merkel bis zuletzt gefordert und
verhindert schon jahre als lame duck zu
gelten hat aber zugleich auch ihre
schwindende macht offenbart mit
konsequenzen die korona krise wird jetzt
die erste große herausforderung für
ihren nachfolger olaf scholz oder scholz
ein mann aus dem westen die frau aus dem
osten geht nach einer spektakulären
karriere angela merkel die ein erstes
leben hatte als wissenschaftlerin in der
ddr und ein zweites als kanzlerin des
vereinigten deutschlands
wir danken ihnen sehr für ihre
aufmerksamkeit in der letzten stunde
bleiben sie gesund und wir verabschieden
sie jetzt gerne mit den bildern dieses
abends es aus berlin
[Musik]
aktuell engagiert meinungsstark